[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning everyone
I was I was in the audience for for a
talk on accessibility a few years back
much like you are right now and I was
sitting with with some colleagues from a
previous shop and I remember feeling
stuff like well this is really nice
really cool but does it really applies
to the thing that I'm building I was
working on a mobile site at the time and
I kept hearing about all this keyboard
stuff that you need to look into like
that didn't really match to me and I
said well maybe we were starting a new
project so that it felt like there was
this huge gap between the thing that I
was building and accessibility and
looking back I'm honestly a little bit
embarrassed to admit this but I also
like to fully own having been there
because it's it helps me appreciate just
how easy it is to to feel that way and
just help far accessibility can be from
from the thing that you're doing so fast
forward to 2016 I was working out the
Financial Times we're building the the
fastest greatest new site out there we
released last October we replace our old
monolithic web site and it was a great
success we were winning all these awards
we were excelling at performance
security so basically every metric that
we had set out to to excel at we were so
one day we just decided to look at
accessibility and thinking well we're
great at all these other things maybe
were greater accessibility to just
magically but unlike performance and
security we hadn't really put a
collective effort into accessibility -
no no surprise we weren't very good and
well since this talk it's about the
lessons that we learned that was really
our first lesson accessibility doesn't
just happen you have to make it happen
so my name is lui de carajás I'm a fuse
developer at the Financial Times that's
a picture of our office were a pretty
cool place we own a rainbow as you can
see and today I want to tell you about
the lessons that we learned once we
realize that we have built this
beautiful performance things that
couldn't really be used by everyone so
today if you're in that place where
you're wondering if accessibility really
applies to your project I hope that you
walk away convinced that it does and
that it's really easy to get started so
what is accessibility there are many
definitions out there but there's one
that I really really like because it
strips it down to its core
just web accessibility means that people
with disabilities can use the web that's
it I just all sit down to not denying
anyone access to the thing that you're
building to go beyond this a little bit
I want to tell you a quick story I was
in that shopping mall with my daughter a
few weeks back a modern shopping mall in
London Wembley and that we were going up
the escalator that you see there and
that she asked me as we were going up
she asked me so how does someone no
wheelchair get to do what we're doing
so I told whether so different elevator
somewhere and as we were going up she
looked around this where is it and to be
honest I couldn't see it it's only when
we got to the top that I could see as a
very far end of that long hallway that I
could see an elevator so I pointed it
out and she said well someone a
wheelchair would have to go all the way
there and up and then all the way back
to do what we just did that's not fair
and children have a way of seeing things
for what they are so even though I
explained like regulations and and
minimum things that you need to comply
with she was totally not buying it it
was just not fair and and it's that's
the truth I mean this is a modern
builded that obviously met all the
requirements but you know you have that
unfair situation there so I like to say
that accessibility goes beyond not
denying access it's about ensuring that
the access that you provide is fair for
everyone and I'm giving my daughter full
credit for that Coleco so with public or
accessibility in terms of disability
you can roughly be divided into four
categories its physical visual hearing
and cognitive at least will be
considered permanent disabilities but we
also have temporary and situational
disabilities so for example if a
permanent disability is having deaf or
hard-of-hearing temporary disabilities
could be we see in the dotted orange box
they're having an inner ear infection so
for a period of time you can hear very
well or situational disability could be
that you're in a very noisy place and
you really can't hear the thing that
you're trying to here for this noise
preventing you from hearing so we
designed for for with someone with
someone that's in mind by for example
adding closed captioning to your video
you're also benefiting everyone else
whenever we for anywhere in that
spectrum so back to permanent
disabilities well as far permanent
disabilities go there are about 1
billion people in the world with
disabilities that amounts about 15% of
the population and when you factor in
your own user base and their
demographics you can get get a clearer
picture of what that number looks like
for your business so we did that at the
Financial Times and that worked out to
be about 20% of our users because when
you factor in the the age distribution
of our readership that tends to skew a
little bit older so we got a higher
number there so I hear anything like the
SD they have a wide audience consuming
the product in the services that you put
out you probably go to great lengths to
to support all the segments of the
audience so for example you have people
on ie8 and that only makes up about 5%
of your user base you're probably making
sure that they get a good experience or
at least some experience so all of a
sudden we have 26% of our user base that
we're potentially ignoring that tends to
get things moving so yeah I said some
good motivation that's to get started so
let's say I've convinced you now and you
you were going to do this you're
determined to get accessibility into
your projects and it's it's hard and
it's overwhelming and you don't really
know where to start
our suggestion is just start small for
us starting small meant doing that we
install pilot into our project poly is
an open-source tool that will check your
markup against I guess some some
regulations I'll show you in a little
bit and it can detect some accessibility
error
it doesn't detect everything but it's a
good it's a good place to start there
are other open-source tools that do the
same thing but we found pilot to be just
very easy to integrate with our process
and it has a great community of
developers and maintain errs behind it
so it was first this is this was the
place where we started the way Palli
works is it goes through the web content
accessibility guidelines we won't go
very deep into this today but you can go
check it out it's a list of criteria
that your site should meet if it's to be
accessible so it checks your markup
against that and then it gives you a
report of what's broken so we run pally
against FC comm and we got a whole list
of errors it's a lot more than two at
that time and at that moment we could
just go fix errors and then run this
every now and then manually and then
just fix anything that comes up but
until we have something that we could
automate into our build process this
wasn't going to be very efficient so I
highly have sort of a wrapper
let's call policy I it just it helps you
integrate highly into your continuous
integration process so I want to show
you what that looks like in a BSc this
is an overly simplified view of our
build process so we have several node
apps that make up over chrome so one app
could be the front page the article page
or signup pages those apps live in
github every time we push to a branch
and github that kicks off circle CIA
build and if it's the master branch that
goes off to Heroku and it's you know
it's up to production so uh
Palli kicks in here in the continuous
integration step so it will run for
every push of every branch of your
project and it will tell you what
accessibility errors you have so to do
that we just need it to add one line to
our existing build process it's that
make a links and you see there Alec
stands for accessibility
just to know type all those letters
every time and what that does really
just runs palace VI and it's highly
customizable so in in our case every
branch generates the dynamic app with a
with a dynamic name so we run poly CI
against that and the interesting bit
here is they're the threshold argument
so at that time we have dozens of apps
making up exterior home and we had
hundreds of errors so we couldn't just
one day break every build whole
production and say hey we need to fix
all these errors so what that allows you
to do is to integrate poly to not break
any of your bills so if your built will
pass if you have less than that amount
of errors with you you just initially
set that value to something very high
and you'll still have green builds
everything will pass no one will you
know have their builds failing because
of you but you will see now a report of
the accessibility errors that you have
so once we did that we went up by apps
cleaning up all the errors and once we
removed all the errors in in one of the
apps we will remove the threshold
argument so from that moment if a new
branch included a new accessibility
error then that branch wouldn't pass so
what sort of our ultimate goal so it
would look like that so now you sort of
reached like a zero error level and then
since the new branch line has a new that
has a new error and you can't push that
to production so it was a big
achievement I mean getting to the point
where all of our apps had this they all
have zero errors and we're preventing
new errors from making it into
production it was a big that was a big
deal we felt like winners
no more accessibility errors would ever
make it into production but we realized
that even
so everyone was for accessibility they
all like the idea of pally living like
the idea of having calibrate their bills
we didn't really do a great job of
explaining what to do once you got the
list of what they meant or what you were
supposed to do so that was really the
second lesson that we learned before you
set the build on fire trained people so
a good place to start is this free
Udacity course by Alice Boxhall and Rob
Dotson from Google I'll share the slides
later so you can grab the URL but it's a
great tutorial that you can do at your
own pace and this is where we started
our own training so we said we've
reached that that level where you have
zero errors in your app or in all of
your apps you remove that threshold
argument and nothing new is going to
make it into production but absolute up
until now we've only spoken about errors
that you can detect automatically with
Holly so that's about twenty thirty
thirty-five percent of all the potential
error so you can have that the rest need
to be checked manually so to do that you
can do some some other things one of
them is getting an external audit where
a third party with experience in
accessibility checks your site and tells
you gives you a report of what's broken
or certifies you that you have no errors
and you are accessible something else
you can do is having customer research
or user testing and the third one is
learning how to use statistics test 60s
assistive tech yourself so you can test
your own site and sports movie servers
these are not mutually exclusive and
ideally you should be doing all of them
I'm going to go through each of this in
our case the external audit was
conducted by the digital accessibility
Center and I'm going to show you a
little video of what they did
my name is BEC Malkin I have said the
policy I test with us appreciate and
people method choose three pick button
the controls of the videos are not be
picked up with jargon my name is James
okay I'm the color contrast and
readability analyst at the digital
accessibility Center and today on the
homepage I encountered some tax
displayed on top of images text display
the table with images can be quite
difficult to read because of the varying
color contrast of the image behind the
text and we see ad I'm a website analyst
at the TAC I test using zoomtext with
audible feedback the assistive
technology is going to scroll on down
below and just demonstrations in opinion
mortgage companies you know so there's
an empty space here which would be an
ideal place key to put the the
subheading name is jonathan brew I'm a
cognitive analyst at the digital
accessibility Center there is a moving
image that strikes me from all the
content another issue I found on the
homepage is the parasol when navigating
through it I couldn't find the arrow
tree to navigate through each page once
I found that eventually finding the
other previous button was difficult
hello that my name is my Jones I'm
completely blind and I'm a screen reader
analyst for the digital accessibility
Center on one of the articles I tested
there are several headings that
announces read more and they also
interrupt the articling it's not clear
what the user will be reading more about
verba to this these headings actually
interrupt the main article that the user
is reading so it would have been helpful
to me to ensure that the article read
smoothly and continuously without
interruptions yeah so some of the work
that they did this is only two minutes
long but I was lucky enough to be able
to spend the day full day with them
while they were doing the testing and if
you have a chance to do this for the
product that you're building I highly
recommend because it will change your
perspective on the work that you do
forever so after that all of that
testing we got a report back with about
this was like 200 page reports say
giving us all the errors that we had
over the stuff that they had detected
manually so we went about fixing all of
those took a couple of months and just
very recently we got an accreditation
saying is this website is accessible to
this level of conformance and we were
very glad to get it there was a lot of
lot of hard work and we were also very
glad to be the first site in our
industry to get it but it is not a title
that we want to hold alone so we
encourage people from the Guardian the
Post The Times and everyone else to get
on this this is really one metric we
should all be trying to outdo each other
on so another way to check for problems
is having actual user testing and
customer research you may have all this
theory right you may have your a
presentation in place but if you want
your new features to make sense they
should probably be tested by actual
users or you could end up you know
building something that looks good on
paper but still get it very very wrong
so I like to here I want to talk a
little bit about how we went about
learning how to use assistive assistive
tech ourselves we have never done that
before and the team so this is one thing
you can do for free and I highly
encourage it this is some of the tools
that we use you get them all for free if
you have a Mac so we use voiceover for a
screen reader we test using keyboard
only method I'll show you that in a
little bit and we use the zoom
capabilities of the Mac we test a little
bit on Windows as well because they have
this high contrast mode that just breaks
everything so it's a lot worse than the
Mac one and by a lot worse I mean a lot
better because it finds a lot more
errors so if you have access to Windows
I highly recommend looking at what
you're built with that mode so one thing
that really helped us a lot was testing
keyboard only so we would initially when
we just go to xpcom and just test the
site using the keyboard and then go
about our lives and just using our mouse
or trackpad but what really made a
difference was going keyboard only all
the time for everything so once you do
you quickly realize that some of the
sites that you've been using so far you
can still use because they have good
keyboard accessibility but then there
are some sites that become impossible to
use so that becomes evident very quickly
once you completely give up your mouse a
new track plan so it gives you a new a
new perspective to be able to make the
transition easier from using a tracker
and a mouse to only their keyboard you
can use mouse keys if you're on a Mac so
what that can do is that can disable
your trackpad but it can give you a
possibility to control your pointer with
your number keys so you can use that in
an emergency if you're on a site that
has particularly bad accessibility and
you cannot do the thing that you want to
do without a mouse instead of going back
to the mouse or trackpad you can get
away with moving the pointer a little
bit with that but it's really annoying
so you end up only using it when there's
really no other way and it forces you
back to the keyboard so one thing we
realized is convenience to do before you
go keyboard only it's printing out some
of the shortcuts for your top apps
this was my setup
on November but once you do this for a
while and you just memorize the
shortcuts by using them and all that
paper goes away sometimes I don't have
an external keyboard when I take my
laptop home for example so what I've
done is have just made my trackpad my
trackpad really really slow and I've
removed all the goodies that Apple give
me so when I do have to use it it's
uncomfortable
so it reminds me to to go back and use
the keyboard so that's lesson number
three
throw your mouse so going back to that
list of things that you have to fix
you've learned to use all these tools so
you have your keyboard set up it's
really tempting to just roll up your
sleeves and try to fix everything
yourself but if you're building a large
site I recommend you don't don't do that
so it's a let's go back to hearing for a
minute one thing that that we learned
well that I learned I want to take
quickly but it wasn't quick it took a
little while was that if you try and
take on everything yourself it's not
it's not efficient it's not the right
answer you end up burning out errors
keep coming back in factors you can
clean them up so and you really do a
disservice to your team by becoming a
bottleneck so what if what you can do
here is just get everyone involved a lot
of people almost everyone everyone of
everyone I know really wants to be a
part of this and wants to help and they
can only do that if you let them know
that you need to help that you're doing
this and how they can help just give
them tools to do this so if you do have
some sometimes you spend some of it
training training your team and getting
them involved rather than just trying to
fix everything yourself also make it
part of your equipment process if you if
you can make it part of your job
description of your own eye test just
put it out there so that was lesson
number four for us don't take it all on
yourself another good way to spread the
word is making an event out of it we put
together a roadshow at the office where
we set some laptops in the in the middle
of the office and we invited everyone to
to just try to
Peter forum using a screen reader and we
offer an Amazon gift card and surprise
let's look 20 pound Amazon gift card but
people love Amazon so everyone asked up
by so this is a form that they have to
fill out as you can see you can't really
see very much so you're forced to rely
on the screen reader to do it and a lot
of people who stopped by it was the
first time using a screen reader some of
them didn't even know what a screen
reader was so this was a great way to
expose a lot of people at the same time
to accessibility that's what the forum
is it's just a very simple form with
some annoying menu items if you don't
skip them properly and he had some
accessibility built in the way we did
values which is very crudely blurred
everything and just disable clicks and
just discourage people from trying to
cheat but the big takeaway of this of
this event that we held it's probably
one of the highlights of my career and
there 15 years or so that I've been
doing this was moment like that one that
is Patrick Cameron you probably know him
as a seasoned developer rarely surprised
by web things but this was his reaction
to interacting with the web with a
screen reader for the first time in
Patrick I apologize I'm gonna use that
picture for the rest of the year as I
talk about this we got that type of
reaction from a lot of people and it was
really great as we managed to create a
space of collective empathy within 20
minutes or so that people did this we
had all these people just stepping into
someone else's shoes for a minute or two
at a time but everyone walked away with
a new perspective on how people really
use the product that they were building
so it was less than number five talked
about it a lot
make sure you spread the word you never
know who's listening
and you're probably inspiring more
people than than you think you are
before we finish I want to take you back
to how this really all got started for
us at the ESC I was some bug Duty one
day and I noticed this car up on our on
our G report on duty but it is the only
place where we have a durable the
Financial Times it's a
it said integrate Valley I know what
that was and know what Valley was but I
take a pic table card and when I looked
at the history of the card I saw that it
has been knocking around on our backlog
for a long time until my colleague Ben
Fletcher prioritizes Ben Fletcher is a
senior developer at the Financial Times
like myself who just happens to be deaf
blind and he by prioritizing that card
he just made us aware that is what this
was the things that we probably should
be looking at so that was lesson number
six for us diversity will improve your
product will improve your team and it
will improve you Ben's small action
really snowballs into us building a
better product it our team learned about
accessibility and got a new perspective
and just grew as a team and it led to me
standing in front of y'all here today so
to recap just the things that we learned
and just to give you a few things that
you can do probably tonight in under
half an hour so the ability doesn't just
happen you have to make it happen you
can do that in one minute in your
project if you make policy I part of
your build process with a high threshold
just get it in there start getting
reports of your accessibility errors
number two train your people one good
way is you could share that Udacity
course with some of your colleagues and
then go over it later that's very quick
throw away your mouse that takes five
seconds but I just suggest printing out
some shortcuts beforehand don't take it
all on yourself add it to your job
description talk about it in your office
get other teams involved get designers
get QA get products involved talk about
it go on Twitter there's a lot of
fantastic people out there with great
insights on accessibility I'll share
some links at the end of this talk so
yes just go over there Twitter feeds and
just see what they're talking about
retweet something that that you find
interesting something that inspires you
can be done very quickly and the last
one I unfortunately don't have like a
magic silver bullet that you can do in
30 seconds to to improve diversity where
you work but if you're involved in
hiring or yeah involving hire just try
prioritize it and if not make it a thing
that you
talk about because it really benefits
we'll all those things that we just
talked about a while back he was
probably normal to have this be the only
entrance to a public building somewhere
now would be unthinkable to have this
but don't wait until it becomes
unthinkable to have inaccessible
websites the time to make your website
accessible is today so just do it thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]